la fin du festival de cannes avec depuis
près d'une heure maintenant le palmarès
la grande distribution des prix au cours
du gala de clôture avec pour maîtresse
de cérémonie
cécile de france la palme d'or vient
d'être décerné aux frères dardenne pour
l'enfant et frères dardenne qui ont
dédié leur prix à florence aubenas et
hussein hanoun prix d'interprétation
tommy lee jones les lauréats avec parce
qu'elles échouent ils rejoignent le club
très fermé des doubles palmés d'or les
frères dardenne luc et jean-pierre venus
de belgique et du documentaire ont
bouleversé la croisette avec l'enfant
kusturica voulait mettre en lumière un
cinéma intelligent qui prend aux tripes
c'est chose faite merci au jury d'avoir
aimé notre film merci beaucoup
mon frère et moi nous voudrions dédié
cette palme à florence aubenas et son
chauffeur et guide fussent elles sont
enfermées en irak
on les disait favori jim jarmusch et son
joli film broken flowers
ils reçoivent le grand prix du jury
l'histoire d'un homme qui part à la
recherche d'un enfant dont il ignorait
l'existence
je suis incapable de parler certes et
j'accepte cette réponse aux dons de
toutes les personnes qui est l'autre
grand vainqueur du palmarès c'est lui
l'acteur américain tommy lee jones
réalisateur de trois enterrements
présenté hier soir et dans lequel il
joue il reçoit le prix d'interprétation
masculine mais aussi celui du scénario
écrit avec le scénariste mexicain
guillermo arriaga du cinéma américain
comme kusturica lem généreux et engagé à
la fois
prix d'interprétation féminine pour la
triche israélien analyse l'ond
l'émouvante héroïne de phu yên d'amos
gitaï
elle a tenu à dédier son prix à sa mère
survivante de l'holocauste est aussi qui
a gagné le prix de la mise en scène
malgres avec déception en revanche pour
michael haneke l'autre grand favori des
festivaliers avec caché qu'ils me
trouvent lé dérangeant
ils ne repartent avec le prix de la mise
en scène ce sera le seul prix de la
sélection française
il a tenu à remercier ses acteurs et
malheureusement sont pas ici aujourd'hui
daniel auteuil tulette pinoche maurice
bénichou valide a requis à tous ceux qui
sont larmes de mon film et que je salue
je vous aime jolly presse si l'on ajoute
le prix du jury un film chinois shanghai
dreams on aura bouclé un palmarès qui
laisse encore beaucoup de grands films
au marché du palais mais c'est la règle